dard meury et voici ce qu'il manque
chaque jour près de trois faits sont
constatées alors il peut s'agir aussi
bien de graffitis que de profanations de
tombes en parles tu en as et c'est la
question qu'on vous pose
vous allez nous le dire vous êtes
l'écrasante majorité je crois oui 92% à
dire que non on ne parle pas assez de
ces actes de vandalisme
il ya deux poids deux mesures jean
mathieu pernin là dessus deux poids deux
mesures par rapport sur le fait que tout
ce qui est acté de contrôler les églises
catholiques ne sont pas forcément dans
l'immédiat ou ce temps traités que
d'autres phénomènes tels que les actes
antisémites alors moi je crois pas alors
il ya juste une chose aussi c'est que
quand on me dit jean des cantons ni
figaro il y as on voit très bien aussi
que l'église de france a pu être
discrète au sujet c'est vrai ce qui
donnait l'occasion on va voir
effectivement le président de la
conférence des évêques georges pontier
mercenaires georges pontier qui dit nous
ne sommes pas victime de cathophobie une
évolution culturelle a modifié le
rapport entre la religion et
l'organisation de la vie en société
voilà alors je pense qu'après par
rapport en effet à d'autres lieux de
culte par exemple d'autres lieux de
culte en effet il ya une chose qui est
terrible ce que je vais dire mais en
terme de nombre il ya plus une église en
france que deux mosquées ou de
synagogues et il est vrai que aussi il
ya bon il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'églises
malheureusement la plupart sont aussi
ouvertes donc facilement géré est
vandalisée après c'est un autre démarche
de profaner en effet il ya vandalisé et
profanes et je pense qu'il ya deux
choses à mon avis il ya une organisation
comme propre à tout lieu public
malheureusement de casser ces gens
parlent pas en parler plus qu'on parle
pas ou deux gars autre chose mais c'est
la même chose et profanes et c'est une
autre démarche en parler bien sûr qu'il
faut en parler parce que c'est pas
possible que des églises soient soient
soient vandalisés de la chose après on
parlait davantage oui bien sûr il faut
en parler mais si en même temps
eux-mêmes l'église de france dit nous
mêmes on compte pas en faire de la
publicité ou en faire plus d'écho que ça
c'est difficile de suivre chaque légume
quand vous êtes d'accord il faut pas
tout mettre d'accord c'est pas tout
mettre sur le même plan fixe est
majoritairement du vandalisme a fait ce
qui est très choquante et catholiques
mais c'est du on n'a jamais on n'a pas
un profil type des personnes qui
s'attaque à sa chanson voilà une frayeur
je pense pas qu'ils aient comme vous
avez des gens qui s'attaquerait une
synagogue volontairement par
antisémitisme et qui ont un profil
particulier vous avez passez à nogent
qui s'attaquerait par ou alors ils sont
très très minoritaire je pense à une
église
pour la prochaine est volontairement
parce que il y des textures et le
catholicisme et que cela représentait 10
personnes peut-être en france a donc on
qu'on en parle très bien mais en fait on
en parle comme une question d'éducation
générale et pourquoi ce que les gens ont
besoin de tout vandalisé en fait c'est
par principe et une église
c'est encore c'est plus grave mais ça
représente pas je pense une cathophobie
je suis d'accord alors quoi ouais là
dessus c'est pas l'avis de laurent
wauquiez qui lui parlait de cathophobie
on le voit à l'écran il ya une
christianophobie dans notre pays et nous
ne dénonçons pas assez il l'a vide il
l'avait répété aussi à l'occasion de l'
incendie qui a eu lieu dont on ne sait
pas d'ailleurs les causes exactes pour
le moment je crois l'enquêté toujours en
cours sur l'église saint sulpice à paris
que je sais qu allissa quasiment sur wii
laurent wauquiez où il a l'habitude de
surfer là dessus si on peut dire et je
pense qu'il s'en sert souvent comme d'un
argument électoral mais enfin voila moi
en tant que catholique ça me choque mais
je crois pas du tout qui est une
tendance cathophobes là dessus de gens
qui ont envie d'être les lycées de
sacchi a pas de signe distinctif c'est
terrible mais par exemple a récemment à
bergerac qui a le chantier d'une mosquée
qui a été vandalisé
clairement c'est tout de suite une tête
de cochon ce sont deux c du sens et des
choses comme ça donc des choses marqué
contre la religion la religion musulmane
il n'y a pas de signe en fait y'a pas
loquace quand est ce que oui par exemple
des excréments sur des os qui dès lors
c'est la profanation en effet cela
propres la profanation mais ce que je
sais c'est qu'il ya plus de vent risque
de profanation sécuriser tout à l'heure
en fait voilà c'est en effet il ya une
démarche de christianophobie qui est
très très minoritaire je pense vraiment
on est malheureusement comme dans
n'importe quel lieu ouvert je pense
beaucoup de casse pas de sentiments anti
chrétiens à travers ses actes le
sentiment anti chrétien franchement
enfin la manifestation devant mais je
pense qu'effectivement comme le disait
l'autre sujet jean mathieu les églises
sont nombreuses et elles sont le stop à
plus important elles sont pas très
protégées elles sont ouvertes et sans
doute sont tellement protégés par le
sens du sacré qui était une forme de
protection des églises qui était tout
aussi nombreux et tout aussi ouverte
mais plus fréquentés et sans doute
davantage protégés enfin on est dans un
dans un an
historique de des sécularisation qui est
extrêmement impressionnant est un
indicateur qui est très révélateur de sa
le taux de crémation en france s'est
passé de 0 37% au début des années
soixante dix à trente sept pour cent
aujourd'hui x 100 on est dans un rapport
à la transcendance à la religion
effectivement je pense que ces églises
sont devenus des lieux publics aussi mal
protégés que nos gars
nono espace commun et c'est quand qu'ils
ne sont pas très protégée et c'est vrai
que par rapport à ça la question est ce
qu'on en parle trop ou pas assez et très
délicat parce que les plusieurs écueils
paris c'est aussi faire la publicité au
exactement et c'est probablement ce que
craint les crises catholique de créer
une espèce d'émulation autour de ça que
ça devienne un genre ou alors que c'est
peut-être une succession de hasards il
ya un autre sujet qui est à mon avis
dangereux cette espèce de compétition
victimaire
est ce qu'on parle plus comme s'il ya
une raison de dire d'opposer la
dégradation de mosquées de synagogues et
d'églises et comme si on me dépasse je
vous interromps mais c'est intéressant
aussi de noter ce que disait monseigneur
pontier sur le phénomène disait là aussi
le judaïsme est porteur dans son
histoire d'une lutte continuelle contre
des groupes anti sémite
nous les catholiques aujourd'hui en
france tu n'avoues pas affronter de
telles violences au quotidien oui ce
qu'est ce qu'il faut je pense que pour
le groupe ne sens plus large que le seul
sujet du vandalisme mais uniquement
après il ya un autre écueil qui va dans
l'autre sens pour le coup c'est que
donnait le sentiment de minorer un sujet
de ne pas en parler et c'est suscite
précisément cela cette espèce de deux
poids et deux mesures compétition
victimaire et c'est un gros défi nos
sociétés enfin on parlait du terrorisme
tout à l'heure le terrorisme cherche
exactement à faire ça à dresser les uns
contre les autres sur des clivages sur
les clivages religieux mais la manière
dont on va traiter des vandalismes dans
des lieux de culte quel qu'il soit peut
soit allé à l'encontre de ça soit être
d'une certaine manière complices a
volontairement bien sûr mais complice de
tous qui cherche à créer des divisions
est enfoncé descoings dans les failles
très nombreuses là celui des français
marc juste
une remarque pour compléter tout ce qui
a été dit dans les moments un petit peu
troublés où on sent bien que la cohésion
nationale est mise à mal
vous allez entendre et lire sur les
socios en temps dans la rue lors des
manifestations des stades juifs voir des
sales arabes vous entendez pas des
manifestations des interpellations
c'est un chrétien c'est le cateau donc
c'est aussi la manifestation de quelque
chose qui existe ou de clauses qui
n'existe pas donc peut-être que il faut
aussi après ce qu'il faut en parler plus
ou pas en tout cas c'est une réalité
qu'il faut pas négliger
alors nos internautes sont pas tout à
fait d'accord par exemple nicole nous
dit quand on touche à des églises c'est
du vandalisme et mais quand on touche à
une mosquée c'est une profanation
réponse à ça et surtout que c'est aussi
dû au fait que le catholicisme est une
religion beaucoup moins ritualiste
quenelles et l'islam au ski ont été une
tête de porc de robin église en fait ça
choque personne ne sait pas une
profanation la seule profanation qui est
dans une église c'est qu'on vous allez
ouvrir le tabernacle etc
mais c'est beaucoup plus facile en fait
de profaner ou de une religion
ritualiste justement qu'une religion
qu'il est parfaite donc je pense que
c'était dû à ça aussi tolno nous dit
c'est parce que le fondement de l'église
rejette tout démarcation populiste et
identitaire le chrétienté c'est la
tolérance et le pardon de son prochain
et enfin monsieur babineau ne peut pas
mettre au même niveau à un antisémitisme
puissant et ciblée avec du vandalisme
condamnable plutôt sur ce que expliqué
monseigneur pontier et qui poursuit
monsieur babineau la plupart des
habitants ne perçoivent plus ces lieux
comme sacré il ya une absence de peur ou
est ce que vous disiez en train de
recenser les réactions des institutions
ce que dit monseigneur pompiers
c'est plutôt non
n'en faisons pas un cas distinguons un
sujet qui sera alors qu'effectivement
les institutions religieuses ou les
représentants des autres cultes ont
tendance au contraire veiller
farouchement est-ce qu'on ne banalise
pas et que donc une agression antisémite
sommières reconnue comme une agression
antisémite et en fait on est dans la
révélation des deux trajectoires
différentes vrai qu'on a plutôt tendance
à se dire que les minorités sont des
cibles et l'église catholique était un
risque dominant séculaire enfin parce
que d'une certaine manière on va arriver
à une situation considéra que
l'appartenance à l'église chrétienne et
catholique et de l'appartenance à une
minorité
je pense qu'on n'en est pas là et je
pense pas qu'on soit dans une situation
on considère que l elysée en tant que
représentant d'une minorité ça soit un
peu transitoire en fait on sait plus si
elle est majoritaire ou minoritaire est
plutôt là sur mon plat surveiller
certaines dents c'est la même majorité
plein
n'ont ils pas dimanche mais quand même
il suffit de se balader en france on
voit des crises partout aujourd'hui à
chaque fois construit une mosquée c'est
soit disant c'est toute une histoire
incroyable a construit un sec et bien
sûr pas d'une équipe qui se construit ou
très peu de l'immigration notamment qui
est chrétienne qui existe aussi en fait
vous avez beaucoup de consultants dellys
dans l'est dans les écoles et le fait
est donc cgt parce qu'aujourd'hui on dit
à chaque fois qu'il ya une mosquée où il
ya un permis de construire ça provoque
des histoires incroyables aujourd'hui
donc je pense qu'on en est encore assez
loin assez loin et quand même de voir
que la religion musulmane et avons la
religion catholique en france on passe à
notre dernier sujet si vous voulez bien
c'est celui de la sécurité routière
alors les chiffres sont mauvais vous le
savez une hausse de 17 % de la mortalité
a été constaté en février par rapport au
mois de février 2018
en janvier le bilan était déjà la hausse
pour ces chiffres le rapprochement est
fait assez vite avec le mouvement dit
gilet jaune et le fait que ces derniers
mois près de trois quarts